so now we will discuss how to implement
sequence alignment in a more efficient
way usually we compare quite long
sequences up to few tens of thousands of
amino acids and runtime of alignment
algorithms as you know is proportional
to the number of edges which is
quadratic and memory consumption
consumption of alignment algorithm is
also proportional to the number of nodes
which is also quadratic and memory is a
often bottleneck because in runtime you
can execute billions of operations in
one second but to store billions of
values in memory you need one of you
gigabytes of memory and if you want to
compare longer and longer longer
sequences you still can wait for many
seconds when work while your algorithms
try to compute this alignment but you
don't have such a huge amount of memory
which is needed for algorithms so how
can we do this let's define middle
column of our Manhattan grid as a column
in the middle so it's quite simple and
we define middle node in a Manhattan
grid
it's a node where an optimal alignment
path crosses the middle column for
example in this grid we have a this
highlighted node as a middle node
because our optimal paths go for this
node and in this node is an imino column
let's design algorithm to find sequence
alignment we at first step we need to
find a middle node then we need to find
alignment between the source and middle
node and after that we need to find
alignment between middle node and a sink
since we know all parts of a path we can
do it recursively so the only problem is
how to find at this middle
because we don't know yet let's first
discuss how to find alignment score in
linear space previously we used
backtracking pointers to find longest
paths and it required quadratic memory
but what if we don't need this longest
path but we want to know only score of
alignment can we skip storing these
backtracking pointers and use less
memory just to find the lining score
without alignment itself let's take a
look on our Manhattan grid and we have a
first column and we know all values in
the first column after it we can compute
all scores in the second column using
the first column very fondly and that's
the same as we previously discussed when
describing alignment algorithm but for
the third column we don't need to know
values of the first column and we can
simply forget them and reuse this memory
because for a third column we can use
only scores from the second column and
so on and so on and so on and at each
moment of this algorithms need to store
only two columns and we don't need to
store all scores of all nodes in our
Manhattan grid and now we know how to
find alignment score in linear space but
we want to find all alignment in linear
time
and let's go back to our middle column
and middle node so middle column was a
column in the middle and middle note was
a note where optimal path crosses this
middle column let's define I pass as a 1
was passed among all passes at visit
I've not in the middle column and for
example lengths of 0 pass is 2 here and
lengths of 4 pass is
four and let's try to compute these
numbers length of all pipe passes in the
middle column for example here in this
graph it's 2 3 3 4 3 & 1 & 4 our middle
note is a maximum note in this vector of
length of I passes so length of I pass
which we will write down as lengths of I
is consists of from from source i and ii
think i which is two parts of our path
from source to this node and from this
nor node to the sink and we can find all
values from source eyes just by going
through the first part of Manhattan grid
using our linear space algorithm to
calculate alignments course without
alignments itself and we also can find a
vector of values from sync by going in
the second part of Manhattan grid but
peckers so we all start at our sink and
we will go by backward edges trying to
reach this middle column also in linear
space so we will know alignments course
but we want no alignments which led to
this course and after we have these two
vectors from source and to sink we can
sum them up and find various in a middle
column so how many well what is the run
time of this algorithm so to find from
source we need to visit area divided by
2 of our whole Manhattan grid and to
find the sinc vector of values we need
to also visit array divided by 2 so we
actually need to visit all
and read to find values in a middle note
so isn't it too large using the same
runtime as before we found only middle
note so we found on a single note which
belongs to our optimal paths and it
required quadratic time so what can we
do next we can split our Manhattan grid
into four parts and highlighted parts
here should be visited after we found
middle note because our optimal path
stay somewhere in this areas but we can
skip other two areas from our
considerations on the next steps of
algorithms so on each of this
highlighted part we need to find middle
note how many time will it take the area
of this node is proportional to the half
of our area of whole Manhattan grid so
we need only half of the time which were
required to find single middle node to
find two more middle notes in this
separated areas so after this step we
will have three nodes which belongs to
our optimal alignment path and we can
iterate more in more so on the next step
we will split our area into smaller
rectangles and we will find middle node
in each rectangle and so on and so forth
and on a third level of recursion the
total area which we need to take a look
on is proportional to the area divided
by four and on the fourth step it's even
smaller and smaller and during the whole
algorithm firstly we visit visited whole
area to find single no
single middle node in the next step we
visited area divided by two to find more
notes on our optimal alignment paths and
on the next step we visited area divided
by four and so on and so on and this
progression sum up to two times area so
it's actually linear tap linear runtime
of this algorithms linear by area of our
one catenary you can see the
illustration here for example for the
first part we need to take a look on
that one area
on the second path we need to take a
look on a half of area and on a third
pass its
force and so on and so on and you can
easily take a look here that it's sum up
to two so what have we done
we designed algorithm which required
only linear space because every step in
this recursion requires linear space to
find a middle node in a given area and
runtime of these algorithms is still
linear to the our number of nodes and
number of edges in alignment graph and
by using this technique it's a little
bit slower but by using this technique
we can slow down a little bit of runtime
but still find whole alignment in linear
space